carved into a sandstone cliff on the
edge of a bygone river a hunter draws
his bow for the kill
he's accompanied by 13 dogs each with
their own markings - with lines running
from there next to the man's waist a new
study reveals these engravings may date
back more than 9,000 years making them
the earliest depictions of dogs an
archaeological record the carvings are
from Northwestern Saudi Arabia where
archaeologists have catalogued more than
1,400 rock art panels containing nearly
7,000 animals and humans settlers began
entering this part of Saudi Arabia about
10,000 years ago early engravings of
women switched to scenes of cattle sheep
and goats when the region's
hunter-gatherers became herders around
7,000 to 8,000 years ago and between
these eras are the early hunting dogs
medium-sized with pricked up ears short
snouts and curled tails hallmarks of
domestic canines all of the dogs look a
lot like the Kanaan dog a largely feral
breed that has called the desert home
for thousands of years an indication
that these ancient people were breeding
dogs adapted for hunting in the desert
researchers found one aspect of these
carvings to be especially striking the
leashes this would have been early days
for any type of dog as the animal may
have been first domesticated as recently
as 15,000 years ago until now the
earliest evidence for such restraints
came from a wall painting in Egypt dated
to about 5500 years ago Arabian hunters
may have used the leashes to keep
valuable dogs close and protected or
they could have been a way to train new
dogs or the lines might not be leashes
at all but instead just a symbolic
depiction of the bond between humans and
dogs and there's still some doubt about
the dating of the engravings it's
possible that the engravings were made
more recently and that the artists were
just representing scenes from their
cultural past
to confirm the timing scientists will
need to link the images to a well dated
archaeological site a difficult task in
a region with a spotty archaeological
record
if these engravings do indeed prove to
be as old as they seem they would offer
a fascinating insight into how these
ancient hunter-gatherers use the bond
between man and dog to brave the harsh
climate of the Arabian desert
[Music]